[Music]
hey everyone its Alicia Malone welcome
to another episode of Fandango indie
movie Guide I've just got two
suggestions this week but both are films
which focus on characters we don't
normally see as the leads of movies and
they're both fascinating stories let's
start with Crown Heights this does Luke
Heath stanfield who's having a brilliant
year in this movie it shows once again
how he is a star truly on the rise this
is based on a true story about a man who
is incarcerated for 20 years for a
murder that he didn't commit the system
doesn't work for people who can't afford
to defend themselves
the whole neighborhood know what
happened
the whole neighborhood know you've
grabbed the wrong guy
the whole film plays out like a mystery
a whodunit kind of thing and possibly
that's to do with the fact that it's
based on a story from this american life
that great radio program which is all
about telling people's stories the film
doesn't go down the typical emotionally
manipulative path that many of these
films try to focus on instead it gives
you an overall look at the injustice of
the justice system it could go really
well hand-in-hand with Ava Duvernay
documentary the 13th because Crown
Heights waves in a lot of real news
footage of Ronald Reagan and Bill
Clinton and their so-called tough stance
on crime which ended up seeing a lot of
young african-american men incarcerated
but I kept a gun for you
you got your family you got your life
why are you still wasting your time on
me that's not just about you
the Keith Stanfield places character
very quietly very understated
and I truly is the powerful center of
this movie without having to even raise
his voice it's maddening to watch his
character and his friend try to navigate
the legal system Crown Heights is
definitely worth seeking out it's out in
theaters from August 25 the truth is
going to come out
can't leave an innocent man in jail
I'm gonna take you home
Crown Heights made a slash at Sundance
as did my next pick beach rats by Eliza
Hitman you ever made out with a girl
before sure lots of times she's hot when
two girls made out the teen is how and
two guys make out this is her second
feature film and here she focuses on a
young boy living in Brooklyn who's
really struggling with his identity he
has a girlfriend he hangs around a group
of very straight guys but on the side he
likes sleeping with men so it's a
struggle about what he identifies
himself as also with his father's death
he has to stand up and be the man of the
family only ask for something
I just feel about getting high like a
girl much like moonlight beach rats
really looks at the idea of masculinity
in a very soft and elegant way it's a
strong debut for actor Harris Dickinson
who plays his character with a mix of
innocence and despair and desperation
trying to keep his secret locked inside
very powerful beautiful film try to see
beach rats if you can it's out in
limited theaters from this weekend's
ready to to meet
two great pics there both did really
well at Sundance both show these
interesting characters and tell
fascinating stories check out Crown
Heights starring Lou Keith Stanfield and
beats rats directed by Eliza Hitman
I'm Alicia Malone make sure you let me
know what you've been watching this
summer which in these have been your
favorite and I'll see you next week with
a preview of the Toronto International
Film Festival
[Music]